hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to be
talking about acidic versus basic stains
and their uses in microbiology you can
use the word stain or dye
interchangeably so acidic or basic
stains acidic or basic dyes either way
these stains actually are made up of
dissolved salts and we know from
chemistry that salts are composed of a
positive ion and a negative ion so all
of the stains that you're used to
hearing about in microbiology are made
up of a positive and a negative ion in
these days one of the ions is the
colored one the one that gives the color
to the specimen and the colored ion is
known as the plumbing for the other ion
the one that is uncolored is the counter
ion now here's where it gets a little
bit tricky if the chromophore the
colored one
if the chromophore is the positive ion
then the stain is classified as a basic
stain on the other hand if the
chromophore again become a four being
the one that gives the color if the
chromophore is the negative ion then the
stain is classified as an acidic stain
you might ask yourself how am I supposed
to remember this well I had a student
once that came up with a really good way
and I'll share that with you now she
said that it's always a positive thing
to have basics in your refrigerator or
it's always a positive things to have a
positive thing to have basics in your
closet so you can think about it in one
of those two ways it's positive to have
sort of the basics in your refrigerator
your
your items your keys your bread that
kind of thing and so that can help you
to remember that when it when the when
the chromophore is positive that's a
basic stain on the other hand if it's
negative it's an aesthetic stain so I
like that way to remember it now let's
talk about the different ways in which
these two different types of stains can
be used in order to understand this you
need to have a good understanding of the
bacterial cell wall bacterial cell walls
are negatively charged it's common to
classify bacteria into one of two groups
that would be gram-negative cells and
grande positive cells they have some
differences in their cell loss
structures gram-negative cell walls have
this outer membrane that has a lot of
phospholipids in it which are negatives
in charge grand positive cell walls have
this layer of peptidoglycan as
intermixed with Takeko acids to take
look acids are also negatively charged
so whether you're talking about
gram-negative cells are in positive
cells they're going to have negative
charges right at the outside of the cell
structure and so basic dyes remember
basic dyes in the ones that have this
chroma for being positively charged our
basic or positive dyes actually stain
the cells themselves so this is when you
have the positively charged chromophore
being attracted because opposite charges
attract
the positively charged chromophore is
attracted to the negatively charged cell
wall of the bacteria and so the basic
dye is actually staining the cells
themselves some common Masek dyes that
maybe you've heard of are things like
Carville Houston methylene blue crystal
violet
Safran the first two are common in the
grant birds using even the acid fast
stain the second two crystal violet and
safranin are
in the Gram stain which are very common
microbiology stains acidic dyes on the
other hand acidic dyes are the ones were
the the colored ion is negatively
charged they actually don't stain the
cells because the negative the
negatively charged chromophore will be
will be pushed away will be opposed by
the negative charges and the bacterial
cell so the negative charges in the
bacterial cell wall will repel this
acidic dye and so actually the acidic
dyes will stain and not the cells that
will stain the background and so what
this does is you end up having a
colorful background with a bacterial
cells that are present appear to be
white and you know white and an
unstained and so that's what it looks
like when you use acidic dyes some
common acidic dye are ESN rose Bangalore
[ __ ] sins you might have heard of some
of those so that is it for acidic versus
basic stains you might want to review
the gram positive versus gram-negative
cell wall if you do please check out my
video on that I also have videos on
several common microbiology stains
including the Gram stain the acid-fast
stain endospore stain so if you're
interested in learning more about how
these different stains are used to
visualize different types of cells then
check out those videos too and thank you
for watching today at biology professor